thank you thank you very much Ellen for
the warm welcome
may I ask maybe for people to defragment
a little bit because there are some
people that still want to join so move
together a little bit unfortunately we
had some technical problems this morning
fortunately that means I had no time to
be nervous tools that help you get your
experiments under control is the title
of the talk as you've seen it in the
program but as it goes the essence of
one wants to say sometimes only appears
when you actually start doing the work
so in retrospect I think reproducibility
in theory and in practice would have
been the more fitting title for this
talk because I want to talk about how
can we as data scientists work in a more
reproducible manner and how can tools
support it as Alan said I'm a freelance
data scientist if that interests you
reach out to me the slides for this
presentation are already on my github
and I also have this link again on the
final slide consider the following
situation you just started a new data
science project you finally got access
to the data and you're super excited to
get started
and you start making you the first
explorations a few plots everything
looks really nice it seemed to be no
obvious problem with the data you're
really itching to get that first simple
model train and that looks promising too
so you you go you make more features
maybe you go back and do some more data
cleaning and maybe you try out more
complicated model and it's all a bit
chaotic but yeah I mean you're moving
quickly it's fun there's lots of
progress but in the back of your mind
you get this little nagging feeling
maybe maybe there's a bit too much chaos
I don't really take I'm not really
taking good notes of what I'm doing I'm
not sure that in a few weeks I'll
remember what I did what worked what
didn't work so maybe you start doing
something like this you have a folder
where you have pickled files of all your
models
with some json informations on them
submitted data about your experiments or
maybe you'll start filling out a
spreadsheet like that with information
about your experiments or maybe you go
all fancy and build a little web app for
your experiment management if any of
those things kind of sound familiar to
you then this is your talk let's look a
bit closer at like this nagging feeling
what is behind this nagging feeling of
that maybe there's a bit too much chaos
for me a big reason is pride I call
myself a data scientist it means I
should be working in a scientific manner
I should take good notes of my
experiments I should be able to
reproduce my results and honestly I
worry I worry that I did something
stupid while moving quickly and if I
can't go back and check because I've
already changed that code for example
they didn't do something stupid
there'll be lots of worry and that's sad
because I want to trust my results and I
want that others can trust my results
and really how can there be enough no
kind of a teamwork if other people in my
team aren't able to take my models
reproduce them and then add their own
ideas as you can see reproducibility as
a is at the core of all of these
feelings so today I want to look a bit
want to build some kind of framework of
reproducibility for data science in the
theory part and then I'll look
specifically at some tools to tell you
how they can help you achieve that
before I do that I'll have to do look a
little bit at narrow down the scope of
what I want to talk about a little bit
just so that we all on the same page
everything I'm talking about today is
kind of guided by my experiences as a
data scientist if you can't find
yourself here at all and if you work
completely differently I would love to
hear from you get your perspective
the situation I do earlier is one of
model explanation here on the left-hand
side we want to try out many different
models many different features different
settings for parameters but we probably
want will be using only one data set
because we need something to compare on
and arrows are expected to happen I mean
okay it's annoying this experiment
failed but okay I'll fix that back and
real start and I'll restart what I
really well you is flexibility I don't
want to be held back by any tooling that
makes me move less fast less freely
contrasted with the other side when
you've now found found a nice model your
model type is fixed your features
parameters are all fixed but it's likely
that you'll have to retrain frequently
for example knightly if new data is
coming in you really don't want errors
to happen because that means that
somebody will get a call at 4 a.m. in
the morning and has to go and fix
something so your system should be
reliable and it should be well monitored
and I think the rigidity of something
like a pipeline existed can be really
helpful in this face of course no data
science project has just wants one of
each of these but you're often moving
between these different phases and today
I'll be concentrating on the left face
second scope thing is a little bit on
terminology together with
reproducibility you'll also find words
repeatability or replicability these
range and meaning from I can redo what I
just did to I can write up what I did
for example in a scientific paper
somebody else can implement it and we'll
get the same results unfortunately these
terms aren't used the same in different
fields so what is called reproducibility
in one field might be called
replicability in another field today
I've chosen the word reproducibility
simply because I've heard it in use in
data science a lot already and today I
shall mean the ability to obtain the
exact same model with reasonable efforts
there's two somewhat undefined words
here with what is a same model and what
are reasonable efforts I'm gonna talk
about those of these things let's say
you wanted to obtain the exact same
model with that I mean if you pick all
the two models the files will be bitwise
the same well obviously you need the
exact same data the exact same code the
exact same command line or environment
variables if your model uses a
randomness in any way like a random
forest or random bait initialization in
you in the neural network you will have
to set the exact same random seat
different versions of for example
scikit-learn might differ slightly in
their implementations so you need to use
the exact same versions of your language
libraries different versions of Python
for example differ also in their
behavior look at the difference in
floating-point behavior between Python 2
and 3 so you want the exact same version
of your Python interpreter you might
also want the exact same version of any
kind of system libraries like CUDA or
your operating system or the hardware
the experiment is runner but I mean you
kind of already think like the further
we go down in this hierarchy the less it
does seem to matter right we expect
cycle earned to be robust against
different system libraries against
different operating system we expect our
models to be robust against different
random sees because otherwise there
would be kind of shitty models so today
let's concentrate only on these parts of
the hierarchy and let's try to obtain
not the exact same model just the same
model in practice however I
I think it's rarely going to be
necessary that you actually need to
reproduce something what what is
important is that you can if you need to
a little bit like backups what is
important in your day-to-day life as a
data scientist is more the ability to
compare models I've
all the information needed for comparing
models here on the left-hand side
provenance I'm not super sure about that
word again would appreciate some
feedback you see how the information on
the left-hand side aligns with the
information on the right-hand side so
for example if you wanted to compare two
models you don't care to look at the
actual data that these two models were
trained on what you care about where
they train on the same data or not
so you'd simply need some kind of
identifier and that could be an explicit
version or it could be a hash calculated
over the data set and how you do this
comparison there's an obvious UI for
that it's something like like this kind
of experiment table often called a
leaderboard where you have some kind of
metals as one row per experiment and you
have some kind of meta information for
every experiment like here I use the x
them as well as these provenance
attributes we saw on the previous page
as well as of course any kind of metrics
that you want to compare your models on
I have seen a lot of tools allowing you
to give a name for your experiment I
personally don't find that very useful
because it will quickly end up filling
up with useless information like this I
like to think of my experiment as being
characterized by their combinations of
provenance attributes so I want to sort
I want to filter I want to search by
these kind of things and not by a name I
made up at some point let's look a bit
more in detail at these parameter
columns like parameters are here I mean
anything that steers how you get from
your raw data to your final result and
that might mean steering the way you do
your data cleaning steering the way you
do data and creation imputation steering
how you if you do over sampling or under
sampling steering how you do your
feature engineering and of course the
hyper parameters that you give to the
model and there's different ways of
getting your parameters into the system
of course command-line parameters
environment variables config files or
simply having them in code how you're
going to do that depends a lot on the
tool you're going to use and it's a
thought I'll revisit in the second part
of the talk it's also obvious that all
the parameter columns and all the
metrics columns are extremely project
dependent so there needs to be some
flexibility in this UI in fact I'd even
say that at the beginning of your
project you don't we won't know what
kind of metrics you want to compare on
at the end of the project and you won't
know which parameters will be important
to you at the end of the project and
that means that for some older
experiments you have you will not have
stored relevant parameters you will not
have recorded relevant metrics I think
that is a compromise achromatic
pragmatic compromise that we need to
make here that is unavoidable if you
don't want to get into some kind of
analyzers paralyzed at the very
beginning of the project or you want to
set up everything perfectly from the
beginning the troubles now start when
the left-hand side the provenance and
the right-hand side reproducibility get
out of sync meaning what is in the table
doesn't reflect the experiment that
you've actually ran and that can easily
happen let's say you run an experiment
make some changes started it again and
you forgot to do your git commit of the
new coat and if your provenance is the
most recent git commit hash then of
course there will be wrong information
in that table it does not reflect the
actual experiment that was run and your
experiment will not be reproducible oh
let's say you install the newest version
of SCI could learn because it implements
that fancy new algorithm you wanted to
try out but you forgot to update your
requirements file again the provenance
information will be wrong and your
experiment will not be reproducible or
you made some changes to your data set
but forgot to calculate a hash over the
new date
again your provenance information will
be wrong experiment will not be
reproducible so there's really a lot to
remember for every experiment right need
to ensure using the right data as you
need to ensure that there's no local
changes in my git repository you need to
ensure my requirements are up-to-date
and need to ensure I'm using the correct
Python version it's too much
responsibility I don't want to have to
remember all of these things well that's
okay I mean we can tell a tool to do it
for us but I'm sure a lot of you are
already thinking right now that's a lot
of hassle like every time I want to run
experiment that thing is going to nag me
to commit my local code that's really
annoying I want my tools to support me
not to hold me back I agree with you one
thing I've seen tools too is what I call
the zip mode where instead of putting of
using it as your provenance and reliable
reproducibility source of information
you upload the actual source code
directory and store it in the
experiments database I personally am NOT
a super fan of this because number one
you're losing like the provenance like
the comparing different experiments
aspects as well as like what are you
going to do with this isolated zip file
you have no history you don't have any
of the nice tooling that gives you that
kid gives you to compare it to a
different version of your code they said
I think your tool should support a
development mode which basically is just
best effort reproducibility like as much
hassle as you can stand to live with in
your day to day life and this is for any
kind of just trying out type of
experiments and you might have a zip
mode or you might not upload code at all
the important thing is these experiments
are still and your leaderboard view you
can still compare them with other
experiments you still have all the nice
tooling available to identify how they
relate to other experiments and really
dig down and see different plots as soon
as you have found a nice model your tool
should allow you to switch
into reproducibility mode where it
really then enforces that you are using
the correct data and forces that you
have no local changes and forces that
your requirements are up-to-date and
it's important that in your UI you can
visually distinguish between those two
modes so this is a screenshot from a
software-as-a-service solution called
Malo high where they use this nice
little lab I can to identify what they
call an ad-hoc experiment but let's
let's drive this thing with the modes a
bit further sorry consider the third row
here I'll call that reproducibility plus
plus mode where you're not actually
running the experiment on your local
machine but you're running it on some
remote machine and this gives you the
Edit reproducibility bonus that you know
your code can run somewhere else you
know you're not using some random file
somewhere on the file system that you at
some point linked to your project it
also has benefits if you need some
special hardware like a GPU that you
don't have on your local machine so you
start developing locally as soon as you
need to you'll send this err experiment
somewhere remote we can drive that even
further why not something similar to a
CI continuous integration mode where
it's not actually hi who says this is an
experiment I want to be recorded but
rather I work on a different branch and
as soon as I'm ready I'll open a merge
request or a pull request and the CI
will pick up on it and run my experiment
on a remote machine I've seen one
software as a service solution do
something like that that's called
gradient and it does similarly like a CI
system plug into into get up and
directly tells you if the experiment
worked or failed unfortunately has to
tell you this didn't really work but in
principle I really like this setting I'm
not sure if this could be sure because I
continuous evaluation continuous
experimentation both terms I've actually
already seen other
people use and data science literature
meaning something completely different
so let's see what will prevail the
question now is how do you want to work
which of those modes works for you
how much hassle can you stand in
exchange for the freedom from worrying
so you might think ok let's tell me a
little bit about some tools that are
available but there's a lot like this is
all the software the service solutions I
found to try to do this and there's new
ones popping up all the time as well as
all of these open source solutions again
new ones popping up all of the time I'll
concentrate on the open source ones
today let's remove all the ones that did
not have a git commit in the last year
so we left with these ones and then I
picked the ones that I've heard the most
buzz about from other data scientists
and that is Emma flow sacred and dvc
both emma flow so there will be a
tutorial and i'm a flow tomorrow morning
as well as another talk that does seem
quite similar to my talk that also
mentions DVC tomorrow morning
unfortunately at the same time so if you
want to get some more details then I
will give you today please check out
those events let's talk about sacred
that's a library that you just simply
pip install you create your experiments
then you have the publicist ability to
add a resource in this case I use my
data set and that means a hash is
calculated over the data set and
attached to the experiment you can log
any kind of metrics as well as add
additional artifacts here I have a plot
of the predictions I made so that I can
really can dig deeper into how my model
is performing what I really like about
sacred is this idea of a config where
config is the combinations of different
parameter values and I found that
there's some really nice automatic thing
happening here that I defined this
config named config called baseline and
then sacred makes it so that I can just
call my training script with the extra
command-line parameters with baseline
and I can't just go to my colleagues and
say if you want to run the baseline just
run this c'mon and I found that really
convenient to work with however a bit
limiting when I wanted to do grid search
seikar doesn't come with its own
leaderboard UI but there are several
open source projects that build on top
of the sacred database here is a
screenshot of something called
omni board I haven't looked at the other
ones it's perfectly usable like UI you
can click on each experiment and see
some details it's very nice one thing I
missed here is the ability to display
parameters as columns so you can't
really filter by different settings that
you ran your experiments with and I like
to use that to give me to give me some
ideas on how to progress what kind of
other experiments I should be running
next sacred supports both development as
well as a reproducibility mode however
you do have to remember to set a
specific flag to enforce reproducibility
mode otherwise it will not complain if
your local source code directory is is
dirty if you want it to reproduce in
sacred there is a good amount of manual
steps necessary I personally don't think
this is much of a problem like I said
important is that you can reproduce if
you need to I think personally it's ok
if that includes some manual steps
however again with the backup analogy if
it's annoying to try out your backup
your problem is going to do it right so
you you're not really sure if you can
reproduce or not if you haven't actually
gone through these steps
least once Emma flow is actually
somewhat similar again it's a Python
package in this in this case you have to
manually register any parameters you
want to have this plate which sacred did
for you automatically what I really like
about Emma flow is the way that it
enforces that your local environment
like like virtual environment or condo
environment is clean in a super non
intrusive way like you don't have to do
anything and it just checks that it's
it's up-to-date and installs its
necessary I found that really really
nice another thing I found nice is this
idea of this ml project file which is
somewhat similar to like a docker file
and that it defines different entry
points for your for your training
process and as soon as you add this ml
project file to your repository you can
just give somebody the URL of the git
project and tell them to do ml flow run
URL of that project and it will run and
you will get reproducible results so
that that is also pretty cool
Emma flow comes with its own leaderboard
one thing I didn't seem to do
automatically is like flag whether an
experiment failed or did not fail so all
of these that are like empty and the
last metrics column there actually
failed but it doesn't display it to me
in a nice visual manner
parameters however are done extremely
well in this so you can you will have
like a dictionary like parameters column
and just can can click on one of these
and explode it to being its own column
and I found that really nice and
convenient to work with Emma flow does
have a development as well as a
reproducibility mode however it does if
you do not Emma flow run some URL but
rather do any flow run your local
directory it will not enforce you to
commit your local changes and there is
no way to make it do it
it will record the old commit hash with
which is now out outdated so you will
have wrong information in your
experiments database so be aware of that
you can already guess being able to
reproduce is much easier in ml flow you
need to obtain the data in some way and
the flow does not care about data at all
and then it's just running one simple
command the final one I want to look at
is DBC data version control and you
already heard in the name where the
focus of this to Allies you get not a
Python library but rather a command-line
tool that has an interface quite similar
to get and you use that to manage your
data so at the beginning of the project
you would add your data to your
repository on an MLM sorry
DBC works in a pipeline manner meaning
you set up a pipeline from your raw data
to your final results and then when
anything changes if you change any file
in that is included in that pipeline you
can just use one simple command to rerun
everything that is necessary I urge you
to read the documentation like the
getting started guide for DBC it's
really really nicely written really
impressive one thing dvc does not try to
solve is a leaderboard what you if you
want to compare your models that is the
only thing that you get a very simple
text view there's no idea of like
recording parameters or something like
that there's no searching searching
filtering nothing like that which also
means that a development mode is kind of
a moot point and as you can see DBC
really concentrates on data and code
doesn't really care about any of the
aspects of reproducibility one thing I
see a bit critical here is that you
really need to make sure that your
pipeline is set up correctly if you add
a new data set or file or if you add a
new script file and you do not include
that in the pipeline then dvc will not
know that it needs to rerun something if
you changed that file so there's
definitely a need for code review so
that you review other people's pipelines
reproducing what DBC is the most
straightforward for all of all of the
tools I've showed you because it you
really don't even have to get the data
dvc that's all of the things for you in
the question now again how do you want
to work
I think these tools kind of reflect how
their developers want to work as a data
scientist does that match how you want
to work maybe one of the other tools out
there are the right ones for you I hope
that with the framework that I've given
you that you are able to go and evaluate
how well the tool does on
reproducibility and how well it matches
the way that you want to work one reason
I wanted to give this talk that I did
not talk about at the beginning is only
I do feel envious of software engineers
when I look at their what seems to me
very much established best practices
like code review like continuous
integration like unit testing and how
they have really nicely usable tools
that support them in following these
best practices
I do recognize however of course data
science is a much younger discipline I
hope that with talks like mine and other
similar talks at disks and other
conferences we can have the discussion
about what should our best practices be
and how should tooling look like to
support these best practices so Dussault
I want to leave you with today the
question I want to leave you with today
is how do we as data scientists want to
work thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks God for this wonderful talk other
is there anybody who has questions of
[ __ ] our sister that's that would you
have you yeah thank you for a nice talk
you talked a lot about and focused on
the reproducibility with these tools I'm
not sure and I hopefully look it up
afterwards how the tools support data
pipelines to themselves and like
distribute the the stuff that needs to
be done and gathering data and
everything
have you seen the talk about he drew
yesterday and can you I know about he
drew simply another new open-source tool
about data pipelines and it also might
support this kind of reproducibility I'm
not sure if that's a cry I don't know
that but can I ask you to maybe I'm
sorry I kind of want to have this a bit
more discussion also learn from you
where do you see the need for like for
these data pipelines in this setting
okay for me I'm not in this 100% data
science workflow because we have trained
we're training model like on a weekly
basis and applying it so there's more
faster training data is constantly
changing so generating the okay this is
a training data via we using for
training our models which takes a lot of
time is like a big part of what we need
to invest work in and training the
modulus rather stable because we have
this model that we found out is good and
I'm working on it too much then I think
your use case actually is following on
the right hand side that I did not
consider today and I think tooling I'm
not saying that there can't be tools
that support both but I think tooling
for the left-hand side will look has
very different requirements than too
willing on the right-hand side yep thank
you
who has the next question okay hello
thank you for a talk I'm not really a
data scientist I'm or a classical
scientist using Python for some stuff
and I'm wondering if what you're saying
here which is merely I think you applied
more to the machine learning and it's a
data Computerworld thing in how far you
see overlaps or in your search have
found connections with classical assigns
experiments where as example massive
parts of the flow you do has nothing to
do with software but has to do with I
don't know telescopes or my 4k select
romantic fields you measure and use
settings and so on can you comment if
you have you seen some yes interaction
with that world yes definitely and you
definitely need different maybe not
tooling different protocols to support
classic science workflows I do see one
difference though that your outcome like
you or your outcome of a classical
science experiment is the often the
essence of what it's all about right for
us the outcome is the model but in a
classical science experiment you want to
have a paper that really describes the
essence of your experiments
what do you draw from this experiment
and then somebody can take that and
implement it on their own and this is
where I I kind of see the difference and
we don't really have that so classic
signs needs more thank you for you talk
it was great and I wanted to ask here
that you've been talking about all these
tools like the ECML flow and so on don't
you think that they kind of cover all
the important stuff but it feels like
one of the tools one of them covers one
important sink another another important
thing can we do something like
contribute to those tools or should we
like develop something else because in
my practice when I tried to use all of
them it was like I need these but it
lacks something often another
tools has so it was I ended up in
building something more or less custom
which wasn't really convenient because
when here just one liter scientist you
cannot build something really convenient
great in terms of a cold quality UI and
all these kind of stuff so what do you
think about that I I completely agree
with you none of these tools really
covers all the bases
so far they are better the best that we
have all of these are open-source tools
so yes you can contribute I kind of want
to take up again this like this idea of
a discussion not just me telling you how
I work and how that influences what kind
of tools I would use the word rather
that we have a discussion and find how
we work what our best practices in our
tooling could look like and I don't
think we are there yet I completely
agree with you
maybe hi and thanks for your nice talk
mmm I was a little bit wondering is
there still a place in your kind of
model exploration development workflow
for Jupiter notebook or are you doing
everything in like separate scripts
because I I think most of the tools you
showed yeah yeah they were all kind of
working on on Python scripts so maybe
you can elaborate absolutely I do expect
that question um I do love Jupiter
notebooks as a tool for any kind of
exploratory work for plotting for
visualization I do not believe that it
is the right tool for running
reproducible experiments I believe I
don't believe that because of issues
that you get with out of order execution
of scoping issues that are inherent to
Jupiter notebooks so yes in my view of
this it's using notebooks for
exploration and then start using scripts
in fact one of these libraries I think
take it or Ms flow actually forbids you
to use them in a notebook it will throw
an error if you try to do so
one last question perhaps with so many
people I've not been that call yet hello
I'm fellow data scientist and what we a
lot of times that it's very important to
document your stuff I mean you do
experiment
you probably scoped your experiment
before and do you document it and you
get history do you have a separate file
do you document your Jupiter notebook I
mean you can put your documentation at a
lot of places but I think it's very
important if you establish some work for
like this that you have also then an
overview what you have done and also to
do it in a consistent way and I've tried
a lot of ways to do it but I haven't
come up with a good solution yeah I
would say because always it is a bit
different
III can't offer you a good solution
either especially for like this whole
like writing some kind of report or
final documentation about what you found
in this in this project I'm sorry I
can't answer that part of the question
however I want to point you again to
this to the gate mode well I'm not
searching for it now because in the in
that mode you need to have everything to
run that experiment somewhere right it
needs to be documented in some kind of
file that sets up your continuous
experimentation framework and thereby
you do have documentation by the sheer
necessity of having it so it's not text
somewhere it's in a configuration file
and anybody who wants to manually
reproduce on their machine can look at
that file and get all the information
they need on how to get set up and I
find that really nice like implicit
documentation benefit that you also see
in lot of software engineering tooling
thank you very much KITT thanks for the
wonderful talk again
you
[Applause]